I don't know who sent those bombs to
Obama and Hillary and George Soros but I
know whoever it is is gonna look a lot
like me I already know that I I'm
already getting ready for that I that
happened to me after Charlotte's
milk I thought it was really great that
like for the first time in his
presidency Trump was an adult today you
know he like gave an adult speech and
then didn't say anything weird you know
like I was so expecting him to be like
you know a sidebar
I like bomb makers that make bombs that
go off these bombs yeah he just sent out
all the bombs who knew it was so easy to
get Obama's address like who knew that
imma be concerned and Obama and
Hillary everyday I'm a sin I'm gonna
sign them up for Playboy and just
like get them just Michelle all pissed
off all the time
i yo yeah I'm sure freaky fool ahead set
you to playboy during a segment this
morning about Halloween costumes Today
Show anchor megyn kelly stirred
controversy with her remarks about
dressing up in blackface okay that when
I was a kid that was okay as long as you
were dressing up there's like that's
character I just felt like you were my
father like you tried to use the word
pizza I don't remember that they bum me
out cuz I was planning to be Bill Cosby
for Halloween but
you know because that's how you make
blackface the second most offensive part
of your constitute you dress is a rapist
you